[Music]
it is spring break right now a lot of
college kids
put your beers away a lot of uh college
kids why i'm wearing a tube top under
this
i've seen it uh
right now a lot of college kids are on
spring break and even though spring
breaks it's time to relax it's a time to
cut loose it can still be very stressful
well actually i found an infomercial for
a product i think a lot of college kids
will find very useful this spring break
check it out
yo check out what i drew on your
forehead last night
is that a hot dog hey who drew a hot dog
on your forehead wait is that supposed
to be a penis
you suck at drawing penises you should
be so embarrassed
don't let a poorly drawn forehead penis
ruin your spring break
hi i'm ross mcmichael and with my new
instructional dvd draw forehead penises
the ross mcmichael way i'll show you how
to draw a perfect forehead penis every
time you'll learn proven forehead penis
drawing techniques
like the bread and the bicycle here we
got one wheel here's the other wheel the
bicycle now who's riding that bicycle oh
why look
it's a loaf of french brick
now that's a penis i put on the forehead
the dj is a pickle ooh here we are at
the dance club and the place is hopping
tonight
here's the dj's first turntable here's
his other turntable and who's the dj
oh would you look at that
it's a pickle
the dj is a pickle and here comes the
waiter
here's one plate and here's the waiter's
other plate who's the waiter a penis
the waiter is a penis and look
he's working hard and he's sweating
and why am i so obsessed with showing
you how to draw the perfect forehead
penis one i'm an alcoholic and two my
[ __ ] brother is a professional tattoo
artist
now once you've practiced on paper it's
time to draw on some foreheads
all right let's get a volunteer
hey brian hey ross what's going on
what's with the camera would you like
some beer hell yeah all right let's put
a penis on brian
i could do this all day draw forehead
penises the right way the ross mcmichael
way
well that is a very realistic looking
penis on your forehead
thanks ross mcmichael
order now
only 19.95 your dvd will arrive in a
plain brown wrapper with a penis drawn
on